[Music]
hello and welcome to trevor phillips on
sunday
this is one of those sobering mornings
when we who cover westminster perhaps
need to cast our eyes outwards from
london and remember that politics if it
serves any purpose at all
should be to protect our people and to
make their lives better wherever they
live
the short and cruel life of arthur
labinjo hughes murdered by his own
stepmother in solihull is a severe
challenge to politicians
it adds a brutal chapter to the toll of
child killings over recent years and
once again raises serious questions
about the capacity and capability of our
social services we've known about the
problem for decades but still can't seem
to stop it happening
politics is also the prime minister says
when it's not about covid about leveling
up
we've been talking to children in one
area of the north of england where his
vision may be taking shape providing
fresh hope for a new generation
the question is whether that can be
replicated
if it can't those red wall votes that
boris johnson borrowed in 2019 could
very quickly find their way to another
owner
we'll be joined by guests from north
south east and west this morning
we'll speak to the deputy prime minister
dominic raab
the shadow environment secretary jim
mcmahon will give us labor's view
prominent statistician professor sir
david spiegelhalter will tell us more
about the threat posed by the omnichrome
corona various variant
the government released its white paper
on social care this week so we'll ask
the chief executive of the four seasons
healthcare group jeremy richardson what
it could mean for the care home sector
and i've been to the former coal town
ghoul on the humber in east yorkshire to
see what leveling up might look like in
practice
but first let's talk to the just justice
secretary and deputy prime minister
dominic raab good morning deputy prime
minister good morning um
i'd like to start with the murder of
arthur le benjo hughes um
can you confirm that there will be an
inquiry into this murder
yes good morning travis look uh as a
father of young boys myself as a parent
alone as justice secretary i can't begin
to imagine how anyone could be that
cruel
let me tell you exactly what we're doing
we've had those sentences for the two
parents the attorney general's made
clear she wants to rev have them
reviewed where we have a mechanism for
doing so there'll be a local
safeguarding review which will look at
uh the local authorities actions whether
any lessons could have been picked up
earlier whether any warning flags could
have been put up earlier and the prime
minister's made clear as well as that we
want to see how social services and the
local authorities liaised with the
criminal justice agencies and what
lessons further we can learn this is the
second case i've dealt with this week i
saw tony hudgell and his parents paul
and mark another very very sad case of
child cruelty we've immediately and i
announced steps to increase the
sentences the most vulnerable in our
society need to have the maximum
protection
well as you said this is not the first
time we can go back through the roll
call uh kaylee jade
uh priest peter connolly victoria
clambier
there's a list of horror that goes back
more than uh two decades and we already
know part of the problem don't we
not enough social workers and perhaps
not enough
good training for those social workers
it's right to review it's right to
inquiry but couldn't we get on with
doing something about that because we
know already that's part of the problem
well there's a multi uh dimensions to
this uh there's uh the the fact that
the individuals responsible for any of
this cruelty uh could be so callous
there is also the local authority
response and i would say that i think
the social workers on the front line do
an incredible job as part of the
pandemic response we've invested close
to five billion pounds in giving local
authorities the support they need
because one of the things we know about
lockdown whilst lots of families enjoyed
a bit more time together for those that
are the victims of domestic abuse it has
been a very serious time some of those
risks have been magnified
and we're taking the action we also need
to take as i announced with the
announcement this week of tony's law
tougher sentences for those who would
commit this unimaginable cruelty on
children but isn't this rather like
the
victoria columbia case where the inquiry
by lord lamming
way back in the early 2000s
spotted i think it was 17 different
occasions where the social services
could have intervened but didn't for a
variety of reasons
and this case
arthur le binjo hughes echoes that
precisely
isn't that
really where we ought to be focusing our
attention right now look i think it's
part of the picture i think there's a
silver bullet answer to this i mean
you've got to ask how anyone could
commit this kind of unimaginable cruelty
why we've got families that might
countenance let alone commit such abuse
it's right that we look at the criminal
justice end and in between that i think
the job of social workers particularly
those looking at children of uh at
particular risk we need to learn the
lessons of course it's very difficult uh
for social workers on the front line
especially if there aren't enough of
them yes but this is often reduced to
the question of resources i've just
explained that during the pandemic we've
put in i think was 4.8 billion close to
5 billion pounds but they do an
incredibly difficult job it's very
finely balanced on the one hand they
need to
make sure they've got the engagement the
relationship that those families talk to
them on the other hand of course the top
priority has got to be looking for those
risks reading the signs which may only
be subtle
and then with the benefit of hindsight
be more obvious but at the time
i do think though we've got to make sure
if you like a more precautionary
approach which looks at the the risk to
those particularly vulnerable young
children and see what more we can do to
read those signs earlier and better all
right let's discuss the precautionary
principle on a larger scale we're
talking now about covid
um
last night we got a new travel ban
um
actually you could have applied the
precautionary principle a week ago
shouldn't you it's too late well in
relation to the omicron variant we
actually acted quicker than i think any
other country in the world perhaps with
the exception of israel in putting
travel restrictions on people coming
from countries particularly
in africa in relation to the pcr tests
for people coming into this country look
we i know that that's a burden for the
travel industry but we've made huge huge
strides in this country we've got uh
eighty percent of those over twelve
double jab now we've got a third of the
country uh with a third jab or a booster
we've got to take the measures targeted
forensically to stop the new variant
seeding in this country to create a
bigger problem we're going into this
christmas in a far far better stage
state we can enjoy christmas this year
in a way that we couldn't last year that
is a testament to the vaccine program in
particular the boosters which are
protecting us uh through this winter the
colder months with also the risks from
the variants so actually i think we have
done the right thing we've taken a
balanced approach but we always alert to
extra risks that take us back not
forward your number one priority is
still to protect the nhs um there's some
data emerging this morning which says
that 90 percent uh of those uh in
hospital in covid beds are
unvaccinated um and that takes up twenty
percent of critical care beds and
wouldn't it make sense uh if you want to
protect the nhs to do something about
that other countries are now moving
towards mandatory vaccination um
shouldn't we be making sure that people
who
basically are endangering others
uh suffer some consequences before they
take up that 90 of of uh of beds well
look first of all can i say that
again if you look at the data yes
there's been some extra transmission of
the virus because of omicron but
actually if you compare the data this
week compared to last week and we look
at this very carefully hospitalizations
are down deaths uh as a result of
covered down in relation to occupancy in
nhs and the beds that you described
which is pre-omicron yes of course look
we are
absolutely clear people should get the
jab they should get double jab they
should get the booster when it's
available and i'm i'm not convinced that
wholesale straightjacket mandatory
vaccinations other than in those
settings where it's really required like
um
social care and for staff working in the
nhs in in hospitals i'm not i'm not
convinced that that would be effective
whether it's fair and right and uh
morally the right thing to do i'm not
we've got to make sure that those who
are vaccine
hesitant if you like you've got the
confidence to do it and anyone that is
reading the data reading the
efficacy of what the vaccines can
achieve including against omicron with
the latest research that we have
published on friday this must be the
right thing to do so i set the premise
of your question which is anyone that
isn't having the vaccine is putting
themselves but also uh other people in
our community at risk i'm just not
lengthening that six million
person waiting list well you've got to
ask me that question i i'm i'm not
convinced it will be an effective thing
to do to say everyone has got to
compulsory uh have the vaccine what we
want to do is say get it done it's the
right thing to do you should have the
vaccine it's irresponsible not to have
the vaccine that's the approach we're
taking all right look on omicron um
to put it at its most blunt uh
not that many people have died compared
to what we've seen with delta
um there is a case for saying that what
you're doing is a bit of an overreaction
well we'll always get the goldilocks
criticism of too much too little and i
think we've taken the right approach
we're focused on the vaccines the
boosters we've got a third of the
population over 12 with a third uh
vaccine
injection or with a booster um but we
are taking the measures and we've seen
that with travel and i know some people
will feel uh overburdened by that to say
look we are going to prevent
the variants omicron and others coming
in
and what's called receding uh in the uk
because we
we've got to make sure that we bank the
progress that we've made go into
christmas have a great christmas and go
into the new year uh bouncing back we've
got the economy uh
expanding jobs are up wages are up we've
got to as well as make sure we protect
everyone's health uh and lives and
safety also make sure we protect
livelihoods i think we've taken a
balanced approach i was hoping you
wouldn't bring up christmas but you have
so let me
the
just
ask
hoping that wouldn't bring up christmas
because i haven't because
i know i have to ask you the tabloid
questions okay in the christmas season
yeah some ministers are telling us that
we can have parties some are telling us
that we can't do what's natural under
the mistletoe now i i see that um the
conservative party chairman um oliver
dowden uh is going ahead with the uh
party headquarters um
christmas party uh have you um
sorted out the ministry of justice
christian party you can have one i take
it well first of all the rule is very
clear people can go in and have
christmas parties of course employers
will want to think common sense about
how they do that we we we don't want to
um uh substitute for the for that
discretion and that common sense i we
won't be having a ministry of justice
wide
christmas party this year um but uh
we'll be having i think appropriate uh
drinks at a smaller scale what does an
appropriate drink look like in this
context and i'm not you may want to
reflect on what happened last year but
what what does an appropriate and this
is quite a serious point actually
because lots of us are being asked
to get to join our colleagues what is
right and what is wrong here what's
advised well so the right thing to do is
for every employer to take a common
sense view we want let me be absolutely
clear government wants people to be able
to enjoy christmas this year that means
people should feel
free to go and enjoy those
celebrations and every employer will
think about the right way to do it and
and i'm the same as anyone else so
you're not really offering any guidance
now we are we're saying with the
guidance we're offering is we say first
of all you can have those christmas
events second of all we want to allow
the common sense discretion of employers
to make the right call all right let's
move on to your own particular area you
are um signaling today and i think this
week that you're going to
get tough on county lines you're really
trying to make some progress on some
issues of crime let's just start if i
may with the incredibly important issue
uh of
rape um and you're preparing to offer
greater rights of people who suffered
um
though that particular
crime
what are you actually proposing on rape
so we'll uh settle out some proposals
later on this week but first of all
we're going to be publishing scorecards
both for general crime but also for rape
which means we can see exactly where the
system is working and exactly
where it isn't working whether it's at
the police stage the prosecution stage
prosecution's getting to court i'm
hosting a tech summit tomorrow one of
the things that we're looking at in
relation to the rape review and we're
going to be publishing our six monthly
update on where we've got to that was
an action plan announced in june we're
going to be showing how we've made
progress one of the things we're looking
at is how tech can drive up prosecutions
whether it's the
ability to get swifter
readouts from mobile phones from victims
that come forward so they're not
deprived of their mobile phone for long
we know that that's something that
undermines confidence in coming forward
the police one of the particular things
that i've been looking at is what's
called section 28 pre-recorded testimony
for the victims of rape we've been
trialing this in the uh in a number of
crown courts i actually think this is
something we need to roll out nationally
i want to look at the right way to do
that the advantage that it has for a
victim is that they have the opportunity
to give their evidence without being
through the additional trauma of the
glare of the courtroom and that can
secure more prosecutions but it also can
encourage early guilty pleas so i think
it's the right thing to do but it's also
an effective way of driving up those
prosecutions the tech will help but and
i know you won't particularly like to
get on to this territory but let's be
clear the cps crown prosecution service
say
that the appallingly low level of rape
convictions is in part due to the fact
they don't have enough people the cops
say that uh the
their inability to gather evidence and
bring forward successful cases it's also
down to a lack of resources where's the
new money to make this work well
actually the spending review we secured
extra money for the minister of justice
i've got uh 12 real term uh increase the
largest for a decade that means that we
can fund um and the age the attorney is
responsible for the cps but we can fund
the prosecutions and in particular in my
area the independent sexual violence
advisers that support victims through
because we know victims just say they
don't want to go through with a trial
not only is that terrible denial of
justice for them but we don't get the
prosecutions and bang up the people lock
up the people that are responsible i
think there's also something i mean you
touched on it there's a little bit of
finger pointing that goes on in the
system you have operational independence
for the police the cps of course for the
judiciary one of the things that we've
been trialling and rolling out is what's
called operation soteria which means
that the prosecutors and the police look
when they get a case not just constantly
scrutinizing the victim if they
made inconsistencies what they said but
the rigor goes on scrutinizing what the
suspect has done and what the suspect
has said that along with the other
measures is helping to drive up
confidence in the system and again we
want to roll that out nationally too
over time the low conviction rate does
not inspire confidence in women we know
that and one other thing that
we know is a problem uh is that women
are reluctant to come forward and report
rape or sexual assault because they do
not have confidence in the way they will
be treated by the police we only have to
say the words
sarah everard yeah to uh
to explain what that means what what
what are you doing to restore that
confidence so there's a whole range of
things that we'll announce this this
week but let me just give you a flavor
so first of all these criminal justice
scorecards which will be for generic
crime but also for rape particularly and
in the new year we'll make them break
them down for localized areas we'll show
not just victims but the whole of a
community
the public where we're getting it right
where we're getting it wrong
i think that's important i'm also going
to be announcing this week a
consultation on a victim's law which
will put victims in relation to rape and
sexual violence but also across the
board at the center of what the criminal
justice process does i think morally
that's the right thing to do i think
justice is there for the victims i think
also frankly from an operational point
of view making sure victims uh have got
confidence in the system hang on through
not just to report it to the police
we've actually seen an increase in
reporting to the police but are willing
then to go
willing then
that is the way we give them the
confidence but we also frankly from a
data point of view from a results point
of view drive up the number of
convictions but the issue here is police
behavior what are you and your colleague
over homo for saying to the police about
the way they
behave well in the aftermath of sarah
everard and uh the issue around wayne's
wayne cousins there are all sorts of
views that have been put in place to see
uh both in relation to whether the
warning signs should have been heeded
earlier about wayne cousins but also
things like systematic practice cultural
points uh about whether
we are dealing whether sexism frankly is
being dealt with properly in the police
and so so those things are being dealt
with i think this issue of the
cooperation the coordination the
collaboration between prosecutors and
the police though is absolutely critical
we respect the operational independence
of both but operation sectoria shows you
how a more collaborative approach more
transparency frankly a little bit more
evaluation assessment of what's going on
seeing the breakdown where those
countries where those
local police forces and prosecuted
prosecutorial teams are innovating and
driving up results we want to say if you
can do it there why not spread that best
practice across the country i think
that's what gives victims hope okay i
just don't need to i mean this is a
politics program so let me just ask you
one question about politics you
you won in bexley uh but actually part
of the reason that um
you didn't do as bad as you might have
done is or that you did do
as badly as you did rather is that um
nigel farage's party reform party took
um seven percent of the votes they kept
their
they kept their deposit um are you
worried about the return of farage
look we worry about delivering for the
people of this country whether it's on
vaccines economy criminal justice but
that would you say well because in syd
cup um for a government two years in we
took over half of that question i asked
you asked about nigel farage i'm worried
about neither
foreign government particularly as the
conservatives we should be focusing on
the people's priorities which is not
worrying about the political competition
it's worrying about delivering for the
people of this country in bakersfield
syd cup we secured in again two years in
for a government from the last election
time where uh historically we come under
a lot of pressure at by-elections we
secured over half the vote with this
great candidate louis french who i will
campaign with and we're going to
continue focusing on the people's
priorities
dominick rob thank you very much indeed
good to talk to you
right well let's get labor's take on all
of this uh and i'm joined by the shadow
environment secretary jim mcmahon good
morning mr mcmahon morning
um is labour going to support the
government's uh plans on
the how to deal with this latest wave of
omicron including uh the pre-travel
tests and so forth
well of course it was the labour party
who were calling for uh pre-testing to
take place because we're very concerned
that the government consistently
throughout the pandemic have been very
late in making the calls that are
required to keep our borders safe very
late in terms of trying to spread the
control uh the control the spread of
that virus and what we want to do is to
make sure that we don't jeopardize a
vaccination roll out the worst thing in
the world after all the sacrifices that
we've made is that a new variant comes
in and completely takes the rug from
under that program and so it's very
important the government get a grip it's
very important the government takes
swift action and frankly it shouldn't be
for the opposition to keep continually
one step ahead of the government the
government needs to take control
themselves
yeah but um getting a grip
would that involve or should that have
involved uh
bringing in plans to work from home or
social distancing
or indeed a ban on christmas parties um
whether or not you're ahead of the
government is that what you wanted
we've been very clear that common sense
measures that taken together keep us
safer is the way to to go and so of
course if a workplace is unsafe then
action will need to be taken but many
workplaces can be safe providing that
appropriate action is taken to maintain
social distancing to make sure that
people are supported to self-isolate and
to take sick uh leave if they need to
and that includes decent thick pay to
allow people to do that we've been very
clear that common sense interventions
are far better than a blunt instrument
in this and we want to make sure that
after the sacrifice that we've made and
listen most of us uh last year at
christmas were adhering to the rules and
we made sacrifices we didn't see our
loved ones we didn't mix we didn't have
parties in the office we adhered to the
rules after all that sacrifice that
we've made we want to look forward to
this christmas and the only way to do
that is they're going to have a very
clear plan for them to kind of get on
with the booster vaccination
roll out and to make sure that
throughout the course of that that the
messaging is really clear because the
worst thing in the world is that the
government say one thing but then do
another and people look at the actions
of the government and they get a
confused message
i'm not entirely clear about your your
own message here uh would a clear plan
involve saying to people you should not
have christmas parties for example
well we've been very clear to the
government to bring forward the plan
based on the scientific evidence and
advice and it's got to be a coherent
plan we've been very clear that we do
not believe that christmas passes should
be cancelled we believe that hospitality
has been for a very difficult period and
it's very important for hospitality that
we continue
in the way that we want to but that can
only happen if we're not undermined by
new strain variants go into the country
that completely take apart the
vaccination rollout
so what about vaccine passport for big
events would you
would you have insisted on that
we've always wanted to take a common
sense and evidence-based uh approach and
of course uh it wasn't that long ago
that we were saying very clearly that
for large gatherings uh that testing
should be taking place to make sure that
if people were carrying coverage they
weren't able to spread it across a large
group of people but we've also been very
clear that it's got to be a balanced
approach and so you know you wouldn't
necessarily need it for the football for
the restaurants we don't want to have
unnecessary rules in place that really
undermine confidence in hospitality
confidence in going out over christmas
but equally we do want people to be
cautious you know we are not on the
other side of this uh yet there's still
many cases that are being identified
there's still many people who are in
hospital uh through covert and we don't
know yet the extent of the new variant
so you're cautious common sense approach
is what's needed
well i don't spend too much time on this
but what you've told me is you will back
the steps of the government's taken you
would not do more than they
have said that they want to do on
christmas parties you would not
introduce vaccine passport you're
basically telling me exactly the same as
a government minister would tell me
which is to say let's be cautious let's
be common central and so on what's your
problem with what the government's done
then
well first of all it was labor that
called for the pre-departure testing to
take place and the government will later
come in uh to that conclusion uh
themselves it's the labour party who's
calling for five hundred thousand test
booster vaccinations to be administered
every day and at the moment the
government's only reaching 370 000 and
so we are very clear about what's needed
we need to make sure that people are
resilient and have the booster
vaccination but the government needs to
do far more to make it accessible they
need to be invested in pop-up facilities
whether that's in
campuses on the high street in
workplaces to make sure that it is
accessible and people take that boost of
vaccination by doing that of course
they're more resilient to the virus but
equally you know the vaccination program
as it stands could easily be undermined
by a new variant that completely
undermines it and so that's why it's
really important that we have strong
borders but in doing so make sure that
we understand the implications of that
for aviation for tourism uh of course we
will begin to see
consumer confidence diminish it's very
important the government have a single
plan to make sure that common sense
interventions on one hand fully see
through the implications of that to make
sure that our economy and our societies
are supported
um
we've been in the north this this week
uh mr mcmahon and um
uh you of course you're an oldham mp you
you'll have seen the
impact of storm arwen um
do you think that what's been done is
adequate and
frankly do you think as
some people said to me uh in the
northeast if the that
storm had hit the southeast uh do you
think that the response would have been
the same as it has been
well i'm in all them today but i was
further off uh earlier in the week when
i went to county durham to meet
residents who are directly affected by
the power outage you know and that was
now six days into the storm when i uh
visited uh one of the first things i did
in my new role in the shadow cabinet
and when you hear the real lived
experience of people you know i i
beggar's belief
that in a national emergency it wasn't
uh considered a national priority you
know where was boris johnson why wasn't
cobra called to deal with this why is it
taking a week for the army to be called
in you know and i firmly believe had
this have been the case where 20 000
properties were without power in surrey
or in london the government would
absolutely have treated it with more
seriousness and i think for people
encountered who i spoke to they felt
isolated they felt angry and they felt
forgotten
michael gove who is the leveling up uh
secretary has been talking this week we
understand about introducing greater
devolution to different parts of england
including for example the idea of
what i think he calls governors which
are sort of like state governors in the
united states you were a local authority
leader would you um favor that sort of
devolution
i do think we have a very fragmented
system of devolution in england uh in a
way that is confused it's not as clear
as scotland wales and northern ireland
and the truth is the creation of the
metro mass has given sub-regions a voice
but the counties are voiceless
and actually if you look at the way the
government are directing money aside
from the red wall seats that they want
to support quite a lot of that is being
sent through
mayoral combined authorities at the
disadvantage of many of our counties and
so the government do need a single plan
to make sure that governance
accountability and investment in england
is where it needs to be
whether governors are the right approach
i'm not sure i think you know kirsten
has been really clear that when we talk
about the power imbalance in this
country it's because people in the
communities where they live don't
believe they've got power over the
direction of the places where they live
and so before we start talking about new
politicians being created we ought to
talk about whether people feel able to
drive the direction of the places where
they live in the communities where they
live and i think for many people they
don't feel that way particularly by the
way because the government continually
take power away from local people i mean
just look at
one of the biggest things that actually
affects your area is physical
development building work uh
construction well actually the
government have taken that power away
from many communities in favor of
developers who quite often are not
working in the interests of the local
community and so if we're talking about
where power says it should be absolutely
rooted in the communities where people
live
okay well let's talk about power let's
talk about how you get your hands on on
some um you came second on in a
by-election in bexley this week which is
encouraging you had a 10 swing from the
conservatives which is pretty good um
but according to john curtis who is the
great authority on these things even a
10 swing repeated all over the country
still wouldn't give you a majority there
is a massive mountain to climb for
labour isn't there
so we understand fully the challenge
ahead of us uh but also we reflect on
the progress that we have made you know
in 2019 the election was a disaster you
know people weren't willing to even
consider labour being in government but
now case dahmer is our leader as
a right to be heard but now what we need
to do is to convince people that we've
got a plan an alternative plan for this
country and that's very much the kind of
framing of the new shadow cabinet that's
very much the framing that kirst dharma
is keen to get out there and i think
actually now the restrictions have eased
and we're able to get around the country
more we are able to speak to people in
the places where they live in a direct
way that i do believe is cutting through
and actually you know the begs the
by-election for the tories was a
disaster uh not least of all it would
have put you know if that was uh seen
through in a general election it would
have put labor very close to majority
government but the truth is that every
day that passes the conservatives are
getting worse they are being found out
people see them for what they are which
is it's one rule for them and it's
another for everybody else and people
are fed up
with having that limiter
at your first shadow cabinet meeting did
you actually talk about the issue of
your pathway back to power which
for most observers only lies through two
pathways
one
that nigel farage takes enough votes off
the tories uh to lose them many of the
constituencies that they now hold
or
that you do a deal with nicola sturgeon
did you discuss at the style cabinet how
it feels to be beholden either to nigel
farage or nicolas sturgeon or both to
get into number 10. well not really
because the conversations that we have
at shadow cabin are not defeatist
conversations they are positive con
conversations they are ambitious uh
conversations and we are ambitious not
for ourselves
people who live here and so we're
absolutely clear that with our path to
government with a plan that's been set
out that by the time we get to the
general election that we will be in a
position to form a majority government
that's a project that's exactly what
we're in politics to do
jim mcmahon thank you very much for your
time this morning
right let's get more on the omnicron
variant now and find out more about
exactly what kind of threat it could
pose to us i'm now joined by professor
sir david spiegelholter who is a leading
statistician based at the university of
cambridge and the author of covid by
numbers um good morning professor
spiegel halter good morning
what are the numbers telling us about
the risk
that we face from this new variant
it's um it's a very difficult situation
because we haven't got a lot of data yet
at all almost nothing from this country
about what the risks are um south africa
there's data coming out showing
um pretty strong evidence of increased
risk of transmission and no and
some evidence about people going to
hospital that it may actually be milder
but we haven't got enough data yet to be
able to say it doesn't look as if it's
you know really severe if you get it i
think that's about all we can say at the
moment
so at the moment your view is uh
keep calm and carry on to some extent
yeah we're at a very tricky time i mean
the the the policy has led to a very
delicate balancing act for months
essentially with high case rates and
what apparently seemed to be tolerable
hospitalizations
uh that have been coming down recently
and even deaths coming down but a very
strange situation where um
cases in young people are going up
especially in london cases and old
people are still coming down and that's
the booster effect boosters have been
we're being saved by boosters
essentially they are extraordinarily
effective and if you've had you know
double astrazeneca and then pfizer
you're more protected than you've ever
been right from the beginning right from
when you had the initial vaccinations um
i mean i know i shouldn't sell a you
know i'm a statistician i collect data
but i do like stories as well and
somebody was tweeting out about their 93
year old grandmother who was trip got
covered but she was triple backs and she
just had a runny nose i mean i know
that's only one person but we do know
that they're saving very large numbers
of lives they i think it's a real
problem i mean first of all you know
there's a big
push now to get boosters out i'm not
quite sure why we're only doing that now
you know it was so clear that these are
the lifesavers we had to get them out
and um but at last it's happening um but
the benefits have been very poorly
communicated and if you if your
hospitalization protected of your you
know um
protection against going to hospital has
dropped say from 97 to 91
well it doesn't sound very much does it
and topping that up well you know is
that very important but if you flip it
around and look at your vulnerability
your relative vulnerability has gone
from three percent to nine percent you
know the opposite the opposite to the 97
and 90 and 97 and the 91 then that means
your risk has gone up three times
so just that bit of waning has massively
increased your risk and i think if
things were being communicated much more
about that um and the fact that the
boosters
massively reduce your risk of
hospitalization and debt then
the take-up might be even stronger
well i'm with you that statos ought to
be allowed to tell more stories because
uh
statistics often tell us the greatest
stories but um one
story which i think we don't quite know
the end to is this um
even if we are still just dealing with
delta this winter
what do you estimate to be the bigger
risk
uh delta covid
or
flu
what should we be more worried about
well
to be honest flu is very low at the
moment not as low as last year it was
almost none last year at all but it is
actually very low at the moment because
we're still taking lots of protective
measures we're nothing we're not mixing
socially anything like as much as we
were have been normally in a normal
winter where flu might kill 10 20 000
people so actually i mean it's great
that everyone's been jabbed over my flu
jab but flu at the moment does not look
like the main risk um to over this
winter um you know apart from covid i
think the big risk over this winter even
before the nude variant came along was
just the standard risk almost at the nhs
overwinter which is the huge pressures
that are on it which we can see you know
and and that's only made worse by covid
cases
requiring more resources and of course
the huge backlog that's built up because
of the pandemic so um the flu is i don't
think is such an issue over this winter
what do you make of the story that's
emerging this morning about the um
proportion of covert beds that uh
are being occupied by those who are
unvaccinated and i guess there are a
couple of uh questions here but to start
with
is that really significant 90 percent of
the beds allocated to covid which are 20
i think of critical care uh beds uh
are occupied by people who are
unvaccinated is that really a big issue
or is it marginal
um that's not it's not true of
hospitalizations the majority of people
in hospital with covid have been
vaccinated and that's exactly what we'd
expect when nearly everybody um who who
is vulnerable to um particularly
vulnerable to covet have been vaccinated
that's that's not saying the vaccines
don't work it's just saying they're not
perfect intensive care is different
because the people go into intensive
care much younger than the standard a
person who um who's at risk with coved
and goes into hospital they're highly
selected and uh and in there there's the
majority of beds are unvaccinated um
i
personally in my opinion is i think it's
very unfortunate indeed that these
people are not vaccinated and they might
they and their families might possibly
be regretting that that decision but um
they they uh they have to be treated
just like
someone who smokes is treated in
hospital like everybody else and so
there is a duty to treat them but i
think it's very unfortunate and that any
um you know
any effort to increase the take of the
vaccines is valuable and of course you
know that's both to
protect people around you but also it is
just to protect yourself
looking at the history of these things
do you think there's a point at which
you reach a sort of a ceiling uh on the
levels of vaccination and that there is
always going to be if you like a
recalcitrant minority that just won't
have it
absolutely you won't convince everybody
there'll always be some there'll always
be a small a small group of people and
um in a way they
you know to some extent they take
advantage of what the rest of the
community are doing and i uh so i i'm
not really um you know i i i don't
comment on policy i i i think it'd be
unfortunate perhaps if there was um all
the vaccinations made mandatory though
because it makes matters out of people
um and
just every effort should be done to get
people to volunteer to be vaccinated but
it won't cover everybody um no that
that's impossible and even if it did
even if we're all vaccinated this virus
is going to be circulating it's not
going to wipe out the virus we're not
going to reach that and so um in fact
although it would be great if more were
vaccinated that's not like there's not
like that's going to eliminate the
epidemic
can we um talk about the government's uh
steps thus far looking back at what has
been done in previous waves we now have
the travel ban we have a
you know exhortations to behave in a
common sensical way and so on
if what we fear about omicron is true
is what's been done so far
enough to stop it
again i'm not going to say exactly what
should be done because i don't i'm not
an infectious disease expert i'm not
going to say i wouldn't uh dream of
saying what the policy should be but as
the previous um interviewee said um it's
best to be precautionary when we don't
there's so much we don't know i mean it
really looks like this overcrowded virus
is more
transmissible we don't know whether
that's because it's intrinsic property
of the virus that makes it more
transmittable or whether it's because it
can get around um you know the immunity
with people have got either from having
previous infections or from vaccinations
so and there's a you know wide range of
different combinations of those that
could still lead to more
transmissibility there's so much we
don't know and when we don't know it's
better to be safe than sorry now what
exactly what that means is another
matter and this is a terror just like
last year with the alpha variant this is
a terrible time for a variant to come
along
when it's probably the next two weeks
probably some of the highest risk um
periods with a lot of indoor socializing
that we know is extremely high risk and
so um it's appalling timing i'm sure the
government would love
not to disrupt christmas
what happens after christmas of course
is another matter i mean the travel
travel restrictions at the moment we're
only going to slow things up a little
bit possibly or you know to some extent
um but they're not going to stop it and
it's going to come in and um we
obviously will do everyone will do their
best to stop it spreading but um you
know where the new year is quite likely
to see some quite um
[Music]
a lot of challenges to face and as sage
has said that's yeah that could very
well mean more stringent measures i
think i could mention working from home
which so far has not been recommended
but that is
known to be extremely effective at uh
halving the number of close contacts
people have and in the end it's how
close you know how many people you're
breathing over and i should say if you
people want to go into the british
medical journal we've just got a nice
interactive animation there where you
can click on a little image and show i'm
wearing a mask i'm singing i'm two
meters away the other person's not
wearing a mask what's that what's what's
my risk of transmitting the virus if
i've got it and you can change all these
things and see them um and see them
wobbling around and what is an effective
measure and um and i think that's quite
informative it's certainly actually
changing my views of what perhaps i
might do
well that sounds like a good sunday
afternoon alternative to playing
fortnite but let just
quickly if i may ask you this um
you've probably got a better fix on than
most on the progress of these things
in reality
um have we just
got to abandon the notion that this
thing will go away
but accept that it will be endemic that
we are going to have to live with it uh
in the same way that we live with flu
um i again
i'm taking the judgment that other
people have made but uh yes it's not
going to go away i don't think there's
no way this could be eliminated um it's
going to be spreading around people have
suggested this omicron is a you know the
sort of an endemic variant that might
just be you know we might just have to
this is one we might have to live with
for some time and um and we're going to
have to get used to it and that will it
could very well involve as people said
you know top up
vaccines um
i don't know i i get very sad thought of
us you know having to have you know
changing our our mode of socializing and
things like that
and traveling um so
it's unclear what that will mean in
terms of on our lives except i think
we're we will be vaccinating getting
boosters
for the foreseeable future
so david thank you very much for your
time
boris johnson swept into power off the
back of the red wall landslide in 2019
and he's vowed to repay those voters
a government white paper on leveling up
in britain is due this side of christmas
but what will it take to help rebuild
northern towns and cities and what is
the potential political fallout for the
government if they fail to deliver on
their promises
i've been talking to people in town of
ghoul in east yorkshire
the old market town of ghoul in the east
riding of yorkshire
home to britain's most inland port
once at the heart of britain's coal
export drive
like many northern towns ghoul has
suffered from a steady
post-industrial decline
[Applause]
but now at last there are signs of a
revival
this morning we're going to do a maths
test
the 90 odd pupils here are a mix of
those from families who have lived in
ghoul for generations
and newer arrivals attracted by a
renewed sense of optimism in the area we
have families that come to this school
from all different backgrounds we are
very sort of
successful business minded families and
we have families that come from
areas where work is difficult to get and
perhaps
income streams have been hard
and choices have not been great for them
and just watching them this morning to
be honest you wouldn't be able to tell
which is which you can't tell which is
which because they're they've got a
lovely vibrant personalities and we try
and instill through our school
high aspirations and hope and
the fact that you know the world is an
oyster really
and it isn't just the head teacher who's
confident about the direction of travel
when
you all grow what do you want to do do
you want to stay living here in ghoul or
would you move away there's two things
which i'd like to be i don't and i
can't make my mind a pitch either a
teacher or a trained driver why train
driver because i've loved trains ever
since i was born and
[Music]
it's just my favorite thing
and just a few miles away along the
humber they're building the platform for
ghouls future prosperity
the german transport company siemens is
developing this site into a 200 million
pound manufacturing facility
they have orders to build the next
generation of rolling stock for
customers including the london
underground and the company is dug in
for the long haul
we are a business to community being in
the community working in the community
taking the knowledge we have imparting
that into the community inspiring people
giving giving people a pride in a sense
of place i think that's been lacking in
many places giving people that they're
from some place they should be proud of
that place to know the heritage of the
place but actually also to think what's
important what's achievable to change
the narrative around places like this
that's why this is so cool we we have a
customer in london tfl who's buying
trains for us that'll be manufactured
here in ghoul
by a company that is in the community
supporting the community
while everyone welcomes what siemens is
doing here in ghoul there are those who
think that it should not just be left to
private enterprise to drive the north's
industrial regeneration
government 2 has a role to play but
there are calls for that political power
not to be hoarded in whitehall but
devolved to regions like this
there's a lot of cash that's going to go
into leveling up
it's not just the amount of money but
it's how it's spent
who decides
the challenge here has to be that
whitehall can't decide
whitehall can do many things well and it
can probably deal with the big
businesses like siemens but when it
comes to those more detailed discussions
a civil servant in whitehall can never
be across the detail of what's going to
bring local smes
for instance to the buildings behind me
which are going to be the clustering of
businesses around this particular
factory and that does require local
leaders to be more empowered and it
requires industrialists to have people
there who they can deal with
you are too bright
whatever the government's plans and
future timetables for delivery there is
no doubting the impact one company is
having here who can tell me about
siemens
it's a factory that makes trains and
vehicles like this
they
work really hard to
make these trains
and make different types of vehicles
and they're really
trying really hard
siemens promotion of a primary
engineering program to help get these
kids trained up in the necessary skills
for jobs at the factory is already
proving to be a big hit
if big companies like siemens keep
investing in places like google then i'm
really optimistic because they give
opportunity they give opportunities for
um young people
to invest in their own area if they want
to because there's the structures there
to do that and they can work at any
level they can be in britain they can do
top level work within their own
community but they can also
aspire to work internationally or go all
over the world or have you know
big ambitious
ideas about being successful
it's almost impossible not to be
uplifted by the optimism that we found
here it's not just the jobs or the new
infrastructure it is the sense that this
town
has found a purpose again and that it
will have status and respect and
even a bit of love
but to make leveling up work this is
going to have to happen in hundreds of
places across the country
and if it doesn't
boris johnson and his government are
going to pay a pretty high political
price
it's high stakes for the prime minister
as well
because this has been what he'll be
remembered by does he make leveling up a
reality he wants it to be a reality but
can he push it through government can he
push it through treasury and there's
real question marks there and a
government that can't deliver more
successful towns is a government that
will have a lot of questions to answer
at the next general election
boris johnson has already marked his
place in history as the prime minister
who succeeded in his promise to deliver
brexit
a new government white paper on
levelling up is due this side of
christmas the prime minister wants to be
remembered for keeping his promise to
those who gifted him with a landslide
if he doesn't the season of good will
he's enjoyed so far in towns like ghoul
could rapidly freeze into a winter of
discontent
a government white paper on social care
was released this week promising to
spend more than five billion pounds over
three years boris johnson's failed to
end the often crippling builds faced by
many in old age announcing a cap on care
costs for adults in england from october
2023
so what could this mean for the social
care sector
the chief executive of the four seasons
healthcare group jeremy richardson
is with us good morning mr richardson um
how worried is the care sector about uh
the facing a winter crisis with omicron
and everything else
morning trevor i think the secretary is
really worried at the moment not
necessarily because of the threat faced
by omicron but because of the bigger
challenges the wider issues that we've
got which are long term and not just in
the moment
so you think that there could well be a
winter crisis um
as bad as it was last winter
well look i i don't think the sector is
going to collapse tomorrow but it's
gradually falling over and the problem
is that incrementally you're seeing a
decline in the quality of services so so
if we look at the social care reform
that's just been announced you know i
applaud the intent that the government
has undertaken because they are the
first government in many decades to try
to tackle the problem
the issue is that the execution is
really disappointing somebody last week
described it as an underpowered saloon
car when what's required is a formula
one racing car and i think that's
probably quite apt
i want to come to the social care
reforms in a second but before we do
that can i just ask you about the impact
of the government's mandate
that all staff should be jabbed i know
that you and
some of your colleagues were concerned
that this would have an impact on staff
numbers what do you know so far
well look i've been really clear and
i've said i didn't think that mandating
the vaccine was the right thing to do
and i still think that that's the case
and unfortunately that ship has now
sailed um
we have lost about 200 staff members so
that's 200 really hard working members
of team who are providing care
to our residents on the day today
if i may ask
200 people we think have left the
business so 49 people left on the 11th
of november so those were the people
that we had to dismiss but then you've
got the title of what number what's what
is your workforce so we have 12 and a
half thousand team members 49 left on
the final day but we estimate that 200
left in the run-up so in total we've
lost about 1.6 of our workforce and what
you've got to bear in mind is that the
time that we had to get rid of those
people we already had 95 of our team
fully vaccinated double jabbed providing
protection to themselves and also to the
residents so i think in a situation like
that what you have to do is weigh up
relative risk and the greater risk to my
residents today is that i don't have
enough team members to look after them
and provide really good quality care
than the risk presented by transmission
of the virus itself
so let's talk about the social care
reform to see whether
what the government's brought forward um
might help uh to
deal with that risk from what you said
earlier on uh you don't think much much
of it it clearly didn't meet your
expectations
well no i mean as i say i applaud the
intent so so the prime minister has
stood up and he's told the public that
the social care issues are going to be
solved and if you're a member of the
public then you rightly believe that the
problem has been sold because that's
what the prime minister has told you
that the problem is that all that's been
announced is a short-term funding plan
for the nhs so 36 billion pounds is
going to be raised over the next three
years
31.6 billion of that is going into the
nhs so any 5.4 billion is going into
social care that's 1.8 billion a year
and it's widely accepted by all experts
that the sector needs between seven to
10 billion a year just to stand still
so unfortunately if you're going to
announce that you're fixing social care
don't just fund the nhs there isn't
enough funding going into the sector
that's one of the problems
and the second issue is that it's not
tackling today's issues the money that
we are going to receive in the bulk is
coming in three years time and that's
assuming that the nhs choose to hand it
back over at that stage
uh if i may i when i spoke to mr sunak
some weeks ago about this uh his
argument was that you couldn't you
couldn't spend that money tomorrow and
what you needed to do was to build it up
so that in three years time you were
getting the the bulk of it and that over
time that that number would build up um
did you accept that argument
no of course i don't i mean that's a
really convenient thing for him to say
because that it allows him to justify
not putting the funding into social care
today that it really needs
so so no i absolutely disagree with that
the fundamental issue here is that the
true cost of care so what it costs to
look after people safely and to provide
them with a really good quality of life
is not provided by the local authorities
so if additional funding came into the
sector now what you would see is an
increase in the average weekly fee
provided by local authorities and i
absolutely could spend that money
because the first thing i do is i'd
start to pay the team who are working so
hard in our homes what they're really
worth at the moment is very difficult
for us to do that because our revenues
are capped by local authorities which in
turn are capped by the lack of funding
provided by central government
i mean all round it sounds like uh you
are really rather despairing
both of the current situation and also
the impact of the government's uh
plans as published in in their white
paper
well look i'm not despairing because we
are very fortunate at both as a company
and as a country that we have so many
phenomenally hard working people in
social care
i'm despairing beca but then i am
despairing in the context of the
finances because i don't think we've
solved the issues
and we will simply continue to see a
deterioration and gradual erosion if
we're not careful of the services that
we're able to deliver to people and i
think we have to ask ourselves as a
country you know what is it that's
important to us do we want to give our
elderly people dignity and quality of
life in their old age or do we want to
simply ignore them and i think the risk
is that unless we put proper funding
into the sector unless we really grapple
with the issue then we're just going to
see a slow deterioration of the quality
of service we provide and i'm more i
don't think that's morally right i think
we we owe it to our elderly people to
provide the best quality of care that we
possibly can
thank you very much indeed for your time
this morning uh mr richardson
thank you very much thank you very much
that's uh all that we've got time for
today on trevor phillips on sunday i
want to leave you where we began
perhaps remembering that the purpose of
politics is to help people have better
lives or indeed keep their lives at all
and we'll remember this morning arthur
levinger hughes
after the break we'll be analyzing what
we heard on the program from the deputy
prime minister dominic raab and my other
guests that's on the take with our
deputy political editor sam coates stay
with us
[Music]
you